OK, we have a funny voicemail for you today.
The I don't know if people are now starting
to troll me.
I don't think so from the content of this
voicemail.
But you've got to turn your radio down or
pause the podcast when you call in.
Here's another caller who calls in with my
voice blaring in the background.
Take a listen.
Remember the phone number 2 1 9 2, David P..
Call any time of day, even in the middle of
the night, as this gentleman did.
Oh, that was to pass without a call.
Listen, I miss our chance.
Got the program.
I can't believe the idiots are calling you
and partners your work worth your time.
Stories of people with phony accents and stuff
like that.
I'm interested in your opinion.
Right after they're done.
New firms book The War Against All America,
All Puerto Ricans.
I think I read the book and would like your
opinion on that figure.
Even if a lot of this stuff, I don't know
what it is, but hearing my own voice so loudly
in the background with the caller having strained
their voice to talk over it, it cracks me
up.
But remember, turn your radio down.
Pause the podcast as far as the book.
This gentleman is asking about.
I have not read it.
So I would not be able to comment on the bonus
show today.
Republicans could lose the Senate.
We're going to talk about how it could happen.
We're going to talk about what are the important
metrics to look at.
As of right now, we've been covering the 2020
Senate election.
Big picture for over a year.
It was not looking good at all for Democrats
for quite some time.
The coronavirus fiasco and Trump's mishandling
could more notably open the door for Democrats
to take control of the Senate in November.
Number two, China is installing surveillance
cameras outside people's front doors for quarantine
isolation purposes.
And in some cases, even inside people's cameras.
We're going to talk about the circumstances
and the legal basis for that.
And lastly, a court has ruled that Detroit
students have a constitutional right to an
education.
What does that mean and what are the practical
implications?
We will discuss that on today's bonus show.
I will be joined by David Pakman show producer
Pat Ford.
And we will see how his quarantine is holding
up.
Sign up today and get instant access to the
bonus show.
Two ways to do it.
Become a member at join Packman dot com coupon
code 20:20 now will save you 66 percent off
of the cost of a membership.
That's one way to get access to the bonus
show.
The other way to get access is to become a
patron at Patry on dot com slash David Pakman
show, both extremely valued and really appreciate
everybody who has signed up or contributed
one way or the other over the last couple
of weeks.
I will speak to you on the bonus show or otherwise.
We'll be back with a brand new program.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dicom.